hey guys how are you doing
hi christina very well thank you thank
you for talking to me about this i
absolutely
love this series i'm from los angeles so
disneyland
is my theme park and i've been going
there since i was
very young have been frequently continue
to go and
somehow manage to work it so that i
actually cover theme parks as part of my
job
so i appreciate you talking to me about
this
that's great we're excited to talk about
it i'm curious what
was each of your first disney theme park
experience
and when did you realize that there was
more to it that there was
so much more than just what you see
so i'll start i guess um i actually grew
up
uh 10 minutes away from disneyland and
so
this was back in the day when we had the
ticket books and so of course
it was a different level to get in and i
i will say that disneyland was an
extension of our my backyard practically
and my parents
loved to bring us in on the weekends and
so it was it was the world in which i
imagined things
um so like to to to
to to be here right to be an imagineer i
mean
i i started wanting to be a fantasyland
girl
when i was a little girl because i loved
that sense of wonder and then
when i got into high school and realized
wait a second there are people that
design this stuff and build it like why
not just want to be that
and that's when i realized imagineering
was a thing and that's
and i wanted to be an imagineer from
that point forward and i'm so grateful
not only to be an imagineer but to to be
at disneyland and overseeing what we do
for imagineering there
so pretty special well today we have 12
parks around the world
but when i was growing up we only had
one with disneyland
and i was living back east so that was
like
that was like the journey to go out to
california and experience a magical
place
so years later when disney world was
built and we got to take our first trip
down to florida
that's when it sort of hit me that wow
this is big this is different
this is somebody designed this somebody
built this
and again i didn't think in terms of who
and how but just the fact that this
didn't
somebody didn't you know pour some water
plant in the seed this thing grew
somebody actually had to design and
build this place and then as i delved
deeper into it and understood the
different disciplines involved and the
the interaction between the disciplines
the integration of the final product
that's when i really realized wow this
this is
not just magical for the final product
but this is amazing for the process also
when did you guys set your sights on a
career in disney imagineering i mean was
it
something that how did you know that
that was what you wanted to do and how
did you actually
set yourself on that path to make it
happen oh i was pretty similarly focused
i knew in high school right i mean
again and so i did all amazingly
all the things i set out to do you know
i wanted to be a storybook land
fantasyland girl
uh when i was a kid and i you know my
senior in high school i became the
storybook land fantasyland girl that i
dreamed of but i even
chose where to go in college because i
wanted to still work at disneyland
i thought that working in the parks
would make me a better designer
so i i am so grateful i feel so lucky
to be in this role now right um and i
you know i know there are many
imagineers that have been in the same
boat but we imagine you've come from
so many different walks of life so many
different perspectives um
there are many imagineers that that
we're super talented never been to our
parks
that fall in love and become a fan once
they start working for us so
you know my my story is not unique
because there are those of us that have
loved it our whole lives and i'm that
person and i
again feel so grateful to be that but
you know that's that's that's
that's not everyone and imagineers come
from everywhere with all kinds of walks
of life to make the magic that you see
today i went to school as an engineer
and and after that owned my own software
company so i was very technical
and then in thinking about you know wow
they do make those
those attractions yeah but i'm looking
more into it i said yeah
but i don't want to go the engineering
route i want to go the creative route i
want to be a concept person a concept
designer
so that that was the leap for me was was
how to how to take that technical
background
and transition onto a creative path and
i was able to do that and and
and be successful but because i also had
the background in engineering that also
meant that i got to play this liaison
in between type of role to help the
creative group
understand the technical and to help the
technical group understand the creative
and and that has helped me during my
career imagineering to be this this
person in between
jeanette since you oversee everything
going on at the disneyland resort
what are you most proud of with your
most recent opening with avengers campus
and how guests are responding
to that new land really in real time as
they're experiencing it
well i mean there's so many things i i
am
so proud of right i mean disneyland just
reopened and we're back and better than
ever and there were so many
uh classics that we got to refresh like
snow white
enchanted wish and haunted mansion and
the carousel but avengers campus
near and dear to my heart incredibly
special my kids and this is why we do it
you know imagineers do it
not for just who we were once for me as
a little girl but for
our families our friends our loved ones
and our own children and my
my boys are huge fans of spider-man and
the avengers and so they
they wanted to be superheroes so to take
them through the land
for them to enjoy to see spider-man
flying through the air at
crazy heights i mean that and to see
that look of wonder or not although i
will say they did not know that that
spider-man was a robot
but that just looks to say oh yeah wow
spider-man's flying through the air and
then here comes that spider-man and
here's his personality
like i'm proud of that i'm proud of us
being able to
to to do these things and take them to
literally new heights right and then
that something like spider-man i'll tell
you we didn't know how we were going to
do that
sounds crazy the innovation behind that
and that that was all done internally
with our r d imagineers it's just
i don't know really really phenomenal
yeah and even just the technology i mean
you know i was at the media preview for
the opening and getting to ride the
spider-man ride
it wasn't until i got off the ride where
i was like was i just using my
hands for that like there was no it's so
crazy that you just come to
kind of accept that and i just i love
that
you know what the beauty is if you're
accepting it we are perfectly happy for
that to be the case right
all the nuts and bolts and the
technology that's behind that if you
don't want to know about that
that's totally fine as long as you know
you're slinging webs great
dude what about for you is there
something that you've had a hand in that
you're most proud of
i i was able to work on uh indiana jones
adventure for disneyland
when we were developing and opening it i
was the
vehicle animator says the person who
rides the vehicle and we set all the
motion for every bump and twist and turn
so i have the world record for the most
rides on that ride
but that was great because you were
helping to bring to life
this this adventure you know we've we've
seen the indiana jones movies you want
to be in that world
and and and watching all the disciplines
come together to make this
amazing you know snippet of an
experience
that puts me in the middle of a film and
knowing that
i'm a part of that i get to contribute
my one part to that
and everybody's part is is critical and
necessary
that was really cool and then to see the
final thing and watch the guests go
you know come off and just say that's
amazing let's get back in line you know
that that's
those are the types of moments that you
cherish
if there were no restrictions or
impossibilities
or space issues for making it happen is
there
a ride no longer or some sort of
attraction no longer at
one of the disney theme parks that you
would want to bring back to experience
again
uh yes adventures through inner space
it's a classic when i was
a kid it was very you know i mean like
you walked into that space and you saw
the eyeball and you saw the shrinking i
mean
that that blew your mind you actually
thought you were shrinking down i mean
of course it hasn't been around for for
decades but but it
to me um i would love to experience that
again
as an adult right but knowing as a kid
the impact it had on me
and how it just blew my mind um yeah
i'd love to i'd love to ride that again
for sure that is a classic
and and i got to experience that when
one was open also but i'm going to go to
the other coast i'm i'm going to say
horizons at epcot oh good one great i
love that
i remember being there the you know when
it opened and just loving it
and i was also on the the design team
that created mission space which was an
attraction that eventually
uh was in the same location so
there there there are plenty of
attractions and this goes back to the
the comet of walt disney about you know
the park will never be finished
as long as there's imagination left in
the world there's always imagination
and and we're always looking for for
opportunities to put
new and and different experiences in our
parks sometimes that means something has
to come out to make room for something
new
my heart is with the country bearers so
i would bring them back closer to
anaheim so that i didn't have to
you know think about having to go
somewhere else to see them i would want
them to be closer to me again
or or to go to tokyo to see that the
camera it was in tokyo
yeah well do you have a favorite weird
or wild thing that has been at disney at
some point
like we see you know the star wars
ballet or the mermaids that hung out
i mean is there like a weird or wild
aspect of
disney that you are particularly fond of
i mean listen there's so many
weird fantastical stories that go into
making our attractions like
you know for me guardians the galaxy
mission breakout and bringing that one
to life was just
weird period and in a really good way it
was like you know
here's your mission statement so we have
the second film coming out
it's like a year plus change and and we
know that twilight zone tower of terror
disney california adventures are beloved
attraction but
you think you can make that work like
and then of course all the hilarity that
ensued because of that like it was
it was weird to think about doing that
and and i
still have uh you know talk about going
dave i did
every ride profile and multiple songs in
the middle of the night which i never
recommend anyone do but that's the time
we had to do it right because it was the
middle of the night in the park wasn't
operating
um i think i went eight times straight
once
uh it was a lot but like yeah we
we have all kinds of weird stories so i
don't know if i could limit it to one
but
you know you make impossible crazy
amazing wondrous things and a lot of
weird comes out of it now whether or not
those stories have been told yet we're
just starting to do that
it's the question but there there are so
many
and it's funny because we are quirky and
and jenna's absolutely right you
the guest is experiencing you know
mission breakout and that's it's a great
ride
but we we narrowed down to the to the
the absolute best quintessential
experience we could for the guests
as designers we got to experience all
the things that that
didn't quite work which helped us narrow
down to the thing that didn't work
but that means we we had wrote so many
different versions
and sometimes those are the quirky
things the things that the guest never
sees
that that didn't quite you know pass our
muster but we're still fun for different
reasons
i guess we'll never get to see that but
we sort of hint at some of that we
we we let you look a little bit behind
the curtain in the
behind the attractions series so
hopefully you'll get a sense for what
that's like
is it fun that to work in a place where
there's this sense of you know
there's there's sort of this running
theme in these episodes that
you know if you can't do the ride when
you imagine it just keep on it because
eventually the technology will catch up
is it fun to work somewhere where it
really does feel like the imagination is
limitless
oh yeah i mean i think imagineers are
greater as a sum than our equal parts
because we are tasked i mean really we
say we are tasked to do the impossible
we do impossible things like that so
whenever someone comes to us and says
hey uh do you think this is possible
sure we'll
we'll try it like so as an example um
not covered in the series but pandora
the world of avatar
disney's animal kingdom hey you think it
could
float mountains you know 150 feet up in
the air
um we've never done that before i don't
know okay
we'll think about it i mean literally it
is it is
i don't think there is anywhere else in
the world quite like it where we get
asked to do crazy things and instead of
saying
no that's not possible we literally put
people in a room and say
how do we make that possible and because
collectively we figure out a way to do
it
that creates an extraordinary culture
and it creates all the extraordinary
stories that we are starting to talk
about now right
that that's a thing and then i think
it's you know
it is fun it's fun to do the impossible
and i know that's been said before but
it is 100 true
and imagineers are problem solvers we
love being given a challenge
but but you don't always want just an
open-ended challenge yes anything is
possible absolutely positively
but when all said and done we have to be
able to make an experience that you
actually
get to walk through the door and have
fun on and and
part of the fun of the process is also
whittling away from the everything is
possible
to the what's the final quintessential
experience that best summarizes
you know what is it like to to to fly to
the through pandora what is it like
to escape with you know c-3po and r2d
what is it like to
those are the experiences that that's
part of the problem solving is to come
down to what is the nugget what is the
thing that
the best summarizes that experience and
that's that's
a totally different type of challenge
but equally fun well as
someone who gets to cover theme parks i
appreciate the little glimpse of the
magic that i get
so i thank you guys for talking to me
about it
you are most welcome thank you very much